well you might remember kristin clark
she's the out of the closet
racist a race hater for documented who
now somehow is running the doj's civil
rights division
because everything is irony so what's
she up to
well today the doj filed a lawsuit
against the state of georgia the reason
georgia passed a law to limit voter
fraud and limiting voter fraud in the
view of kristin clarke is
needless to say racist and in this case
our careful assessment
of the facts and the law demonstrates
that georgia's recent voting rights law
violates section 2 of the voting rights
act
our complaint challenges several
provisions of sb
202 on the grounds that they were
adopted with the intent
to deny or abridge black citizens
equal access to the political process
so there it is the racism leash they
call you racism when they want
you to obey will georgia obey well chris
carr is the attorney general of georgie
he joins us tonight
mr general i appreciate your coming on
so how exactly is
your attempt the state of georgia's
attempt to limit voter fraud which is
real
racist well it's not tucker and thanks
for having me
let's be clear this isn't a lawsuit this
is a campaign flyer
the department of justice is playing
politics
they're not upholding the rule of law
and this blatantly political lawsuit
is legally factually and
constitutionally wrong
anybody who looks at our law can see
that it improves
uh security it improves access it
improves transparency in georgia's law
and that's why it's going to be upheld
so what is their claim exactly how i
mean as far as i know
african americans in georgia and in the
rest of the country vote
as a higher percentage of population
than almost any group
so how and you know great but
how is your law according to kristin
clark the bigot running the civil rights
division
disproportionately affecting black
voters i
honestly don't get the the argument well
you're going to have to ask the justice
department that because that's the claim
that they're making and again
they're wrong and this is the eighth
lawsuit now tucker that we have there's
seven other lawsuits
filed by others like fairfight and
others uh that cl make the same types of
claims and i would just remind everybody
we've beaten stacy abrams in court every
time she's filed a legal action against
us since 2018
and this is again it's a politic
blatantly political lawsuit
and i'd remind everybody the attorney
general when he got into office
said he was going to de-politicize the
department
and then he comes out of the shoot with
this a blatantly political lawsuit
that is not based on fact and i'll tell
you i think the american people should
be
very very concerned that this justice
department i'm going to quote what
governor brian kemp said
the weaponization of the department of
justice should bother
everybody it has now been weaponized by
a group of political
activists who don't like what our state
has done
today it may be georgia but tomorrow
could be anybody and that should bother
anyone republicans democrats liberals or
conservatives
it's a problem well i would say they're
not just activists they're extremists
and merrick garland has this kind of joe
biden thing going for him which is that
he looks moderate
and seems sensible and he's a friendly
guy and you meet a lot of people i know
merrick garland good guy
and then you listen to the text of what
he said you realize this guy's an
extremist he's a radical
attacking people on the base of their
skin colors attorney general really
what since when is that allowed so can
they
force you to change the law in georgia
or no absolutely not tucker because it's
constitutional it's legal
you look at what our bill does again it
improves security and and look go back
to 2018.
democrats complained about long lines
they complained about voting machines
they complained about local boards not
doing their job republicans complained
about the same thing
in 2020 sb 202 simply
addresses those concerns improved access
improved security improved transparency
that helps
everyone republican and democrat alike
because right now there is a crisis of
confidence in our electoral system
yeah but this bill simply addresses
those
and provides a stronger system for
everybody in the state of georgia
and it will be paper ballots in person
yeah that's that's
really the only answer i appreciate mr
general thanks for coming on tonight
tiger thanks for having me at go hawks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else